all right thanks a lot for coming yeah
so welcome to my tutorial I've called it
data analysis in parallel which is I
mean pretty much what it is
so I'm just going to show a typical data
analysis workflow and then just cast it
into a parallel setting and yeah you can
just see my email on here in case you
want to contact me later on and the
slides will be in the repository so the
motivation for giving this talk is just
the fact that so many problems that we
encounter especially as analysts and
researchers is that many many of these
problems that we see are embarrassingly
parallel meaning they're just
conceptually really trivial to parallel
eyes and it doesn't really take extra
logic to do it but yet many people still
avoid doing that just because it's quite
difficult to implement or they think
they don't need it to begin with because
it's just about delivering numbers or or
charts and yet is that it is actually
quite simple if you have an existing
Jupiter notebook workflow and you can
then just plug in i-5 parallel and you
can with relatively minor changes you
can actually get it to work so you would
not need to rewrite your whole codebase
just to have parallel computing
available and you can even have the
possibility of running it on remote
machines which removes remit limits on
memory scalability and yet just another
part of why this is important is because
I mean today obviously this data sets
are only getting bigger we have more and
more CPUs on single machines we have
more bigger networks of commodity
computers so this is just becoming an
increasingly relevant topic and yeah you
could even say that there are some data
sets which are so large that I mean you
cannot really do it an attractive Allah
mount of time without doing it in
parallel so the objectives of this
tutorial will be to show you
interactively and actually hopefully for
you to follow along as well in just
using parallelism in its very basic form
so splitting up independent data and
performing the same computation on it at
the same time which is also known as
single program multiple data parallelism
and so another objective is just to show
researchers that this can be done using
their typical environment without
needing to rewrite more complicated code
or changing their workflow and I'm going
to demonstrate that by running
independent tasks first sequentially and
then in parallel to show what the
performance benefit is going to be and
as further enhancements if there is time
then I will also look at analyzing what
the performance improvement is why is it
the way it is and then we can look at
debugging the parallel processes and if
there is extra time at the end we can
also look at how to run on remote
machines which I don't I'm not going to
demonstrate but we can just discuss what
the steps would need to be for that with
a PI parallel so the structure will be
for this tutorial that I'm going to have
an interactive Jupiter notebook which is
available in the repository that I've
shared in the slack Channel and is also
available on here in the corner I'm
gonna have a slide for setup so you'll
be able to follow along for that and so
I'm going to have this Jupiter notebook
with these three analysis tasks and the
code for these tasks is going to be
demonstrated and executed sequentially
and then we'll see just how long that
takes what the results are and then
we'll do it in parallel and see what the
speed-up is and how the usage of the CPU
cores changes and just see if we're
getting more out of the computer in by
using the multiple cores and then yeah
as I said before for the second part I'm
gonna look at further points of
performance analysis and debugging and
just discussing the idea of running it
on remote machines and then in the end I
would like to have a Q&A session I said
here it's gonna be 15 minutes it might
not actually take that long since I I'm
not sure like if we complete the full 90
minutes of this slot but we'll see so
but there will definitely be a Q&A
session so prepare some questions if you
would like to ask anything okay and so
now if yeah if you haven't gotten setup
yet these are the steps on how to do it
so
you will need to have anaconda installed
which you probably should have done
already from the just just instructions
for the conference then you can download
the code from my github repository or
you can so you can clone it or you can
get it as a zip file and then there are
instructions in the readme on how to
actually get set up so basically the
readme will just tell you that you need
to you use this anaconda environment
file to get all the dependencies and and
then activate the environment and then
in the end what you'll end up with is a
just a Jupiter notebook which actually
is as the code opened so does anyone
want a USB stick in case you don't have
internet connection since I have the
files with the repository on here does
anyone yeah so just feel free to pass it
around if anyone else needs it
afterwards okay so yeah while I'm giving
the rest of the presentation which isn't
actually very long you can get set up
with the repository and just follow
along so I mentioned before that I'm
going to demonstrate this by having
these analysis tasks which are going to
be run first sequentially and then in
parallel and then on this slide I'm
actually getting into what those
analysis tasks are going to be so I'm
going to be doing an imagined situation
of natural language processing on for
tech companies for tech companies
Twitter mentions and all so this these
are the four independent pieces of data
that I've been talking about there then
I'm gonna be parallelized and for each
of these four data sets the following is
going to be performed so these tweets
were gathered from this full of the
hashtag website which sources Twitter
Twitter data sources tweets so that
saves me just having to get it from the
developer API and this is what the tasks
are that I'm going to perform so for
each of the tweets I can do aggregate
statistics so there will be things like
the number of tweets to average tweet
length the total character count
the date range of the posting so when
was the earliest we won when was the
latest tweet it's all from 2016 so it's
quite old in any way then the second
task is going to be to create a
histogram of leaven taste of lemon taste
wheats so I'm going to plot a frequency
distribution of the ulemas in the in the
tweets of course only the most frequent
ones so for those of you don't know what
ulema is from NLP it's just a sort of
dictionary form of a word so it's like a
word that you would cut off the endings
off or the or the prefixes and so this
gives you a better idea of what the
topics are in the text and I'm going
basically this is going to be done for
every single company and I'll show the
frequency distribution of the top-20
lemmas and then finally I'm going to
classify the sentiment of each tweet
using a pre fitted neural net and
calculate the percentage of positive
tweets so I just have another notebook
where I fit this Kara's classifier which
I'll just briefly should show you but I
won't run it because it takes like 24
hours to actually if it fit it but it is
in the github repo for those who are
interested to look at later on and yeah
as I said before these are the tasks
that are gonna be run in secret
sequentially and then in parallel so
you'll be able to see the performance
benefit ok so just to introduce the idea
of parallelism in case anyone's not
familiar with it so it's basically the
idea of running computation at the same
time on different processors or
different machines and it actually has
to happen simultaneously right which is
not necessarily the same as concurrency
because that can be you have multiple
threads but they're all done by one
processor but they're just done
asynchronously so that's useful for
things like IO or just user interactions
but it's not the subject of this talk
because in this talk we're actually
talking about parallelism which means
running simultaneously on different
different processors and before I
mentioned embarrassingly parallel
problems which are those that can just
be implemented without having to work on
additional parallelized logic so I you
know the idea is you just split the data
and you just run it you don't have to
you know change any algorithm
in a big way just to be able to
implement it and that's what
embarrassingly parallel problems are and
they are the ones that are encountered
very often in data analysis workflows
and that is how I'm going to demonstrate
how to run those for analysis tasks and
that then there will be three final
further concepts that we will look at
which are the analysis of the
performance so why is something you know
why is the parallel code is much faster
as it is as as than the sequential code
will look at bottlenecks and potentially
counterintuitive results and why it may
not be exactly what you expected then
we'll take a look at debugging the
parallel processes which can be done by
writing two files and raising exceptions
but it's not necessarily as simple as
just logging to a terminal as you would
do from a single threaded application or
it yeah
single process so these parallel
processes are notorious for being
difficult to debug so we can look at how
that can be done and then finally I'll
just quickly touch on how to run it on
remote machines because that is
something that helps you scale quite a
lot and if it and yeah if you can
implement it it can help you just
overcome limits on the memory and get
further further speed-up even though
it's something on I won't write code for
here but we can just sort of discuss how
that could be done okay so that's the
end of the presentation and I'm actually
going to get into the demo so those of
you who have the notebook installed feel
free to feel free to follow along you
can just execute it yourselves as well
just to get an idea of just you
interactively run it as well before that
I'll just show you what the data looks
like that we're going to be analyzing so
these are the tweets of the companies
that we'll be looking at so for example
when isn't one of them is just tweets
about Amazon so I'll just open this CSV
and show you what it looks like very
quickly before we get into the actual
code
[Applause]
just taking a little bit too long
okay so yeah this is the nature of the
data that we'll be looking at so you've
got a just a large table for these four
companies one of which is being Amazon
that we're looking at so you see you've
got things like date our user name and
then the actual content of the tweet and
you can see the Amazon symbol which is
what it's been sort of captured on and
then you have just a boolean flag of
whether it's an RT or not and then the
number of retweets as well okay so this
is what the data looks like that we're
working with I just find it's always
useful to look at the data beforehand
yeah so you can close that and now we
can actually get into the code
demonstration okay so let me just make
this a bit bigger what do you prefer
this or this okay all right yeah so this
is the main notebook which actually
shows the analysis tasks so I'm just
gonna run through this I mean so this is
just a bunch of imports that will later
be needed this is just some
environmental flags to just basically
deal with Karis having some annoying
errors yeah this just says we're gonna
read 30,000 rows then this function is
just used to do some pre-processing on
the data frame as it's being read from
the CSV for every single company so you
just read the tweets you get rid of the
columns that you're not interested in
which actually has already been done
before but anyway it's there I've I
filtered out retweets because I don't
want to consider them then these regular
expressions just get rid of things like
mentions they get rid of links in the
tweets they get little rid of the
symbols because that's not really
relevant and then yeah this just
basically applies these these patterns
to clean clean the tweet content and you
can see here that there is this IP dot
required decorator which is used for I
pi parallel but at the moment it doesn't
you don't have to think about it because
we're first gonna run it sequentially
and it doesn't actually if you just were
to call the function by itself it
wouldn't do anything so it's just so at
the moment you can ignore it but will
become it will become relevant later on
gonna run that okay so here we can see
that there are these analysis tasks that
we want to run which is what I've
basically spoken about in the
presentation before so there are the
aggregate statistics then the histogram
of lemmas from for each company and then
a classification of sentiment so here we
can look at the first task right so this
is just an imagine sort of NLP workflow
right so this function will just give
you some data about each company's
tweets that we're looking at so it'll
give you things like the number of
tweets the total total character count
the min and Max of the dates then the
average length of the tweet and then the
average number of retweets and then you
just return to turn that as a pandas
series just because it's easy to
visualize that way okay then the second
task is getting the the top lemmas so
for every tweet you tokenize it which is
basically from NLP again it's just the
task of splitting a sentence into its
tokens so things like just words that
are split by whitespace and potentially
other other things and then you do the
limit ization which means finding
dilemma of the word as I said which is
the dictionary form and then you turn
this into a counter object so you get a
dictionary of ulema and the count and
then that is built up in this loop over
all of the tweets and you then return
that as a dictionary where you only get
the top and which in my case is gonna be
20 so just run that okay and now we get
to task three which is the sentiment
classifier so before I actually show you
this I'm just going to show you the
notebook I'm not gonna run it but the
notebook that I used to fit this so I
used this as a separate notebook as you
can see for fitting the Charis model so
here it's just a binary classifier which
says you know is the tweet negative is
it positive and I used this sentiment
140 dataset which is freely available
online
and yeah here just do some
pre-processing then yeah before you
actually can classify text you need to
you need to tokenize it and most
importantly need to turn it into a
vector form so you cannot obviously
train a model on a bunch of words you
need to turn it into a vector
representation and then you can actually
train it so that is something that's
being done here then and then yeah here
I just defined the the classifier model
which is a sort of sequential Chara's
model so you can see there's an
embedding layer which is needed to take
the input word vectors and turn them
into a more dense representation then
there are some recurrent layers for the
actual sequence modeling and then that
you just get the output which is a
sigmoid which just gives you a binary or
certainly yeah then you have a the
binary cross-entropy loss which just
tells you which which class it belongs
to and then I fitted the model and when
you evaluate it gets about 82 percent
accuracy on the test data but that isn't
I mean it's not that great though
because of course the test data comes
from the same source as the training
data so even though it hasn't seen it
it's not really representative of any
random you know any random text so I'm
just going to show you an example of how
you can use this model I've already
actually before I get to that I've
already serialized this in this h5 file
so it's possible to just load it with
Kerris and use it so there's no need to
do the painful work of actually fitting
it because that takes a long time so as
an example you can yeah so you can just
run these imports then you can get this
tokenizer object which as I said before
is necessary to turn the words into
vectors then you can deserialize this
model which is gonna take a while okay
and then as I said before before you can
actually turn before you can classify
text you will need to vectorize it right
so for example if I want to classify the
sentence the weather is just awful right
I can I first need to turn it into its
vector representation which looks like
this which is
sorry yeah which is just a sequence of
numbers right and then I can classify it
it's gonna say yeah it's gonna say
negative sentiment right so if I know if
I say something like it's horrific it's
probably gonna be negative as well
yeah and if I say it's great it should
be positive although it doesn't always
work like this because you will get yeah
so now it's positive I don't know but I
mean there there are sentences where I
can where it should be positive and it's
actually negative so it doesn't work
super well but it's just sort of just an
example of what you should be able to
you know it's just an example of
something you would use in an NLP
workflow and then I'm gonna just show
you how to run it in in parallel so yeah
so you know you can try this for
yourself selves and you'll see that
there are a bunch of sentences that in
classify is completely wrong but anyway
going back to this task 3 so here we're
going to use this model as I've
discussed and we're just going to apply
it to every single tweet that we're
gonna read so we have these you know
thousands of tweets and we're gonna
classify each one of them and this
function is written in such a way that
it takes a keyword argument with the
model and if it's not there it reads the
model itself and you'll see why that's
important later on because it's to do
with the parallel implementation but
yeah other than that all it does is just
take takes the tweets turns them into a
vector and then puts that vector into
the model and then gives you the average
number of positive positive tweets with
this mean function okay so I'll just run
that and then these are just finally
some functions for visualizing
visualizing the results so and ok so now
now that I've shown you these tasks I
think it actually would make more sense
if I just quickly show it on one example
before I run it on on all of them so
I'll just show it to you for Amazon for
example for the oh excuse me yeah for
the Amazon tweets so we'll just see what
that looks like
guess we'll just read in this data frame
all right as you can see it looks like
this so you have the tweet content right
which you can see has a lot of these
these things in it like links and
mentions and that's all been removed in
this clean tweet object then if we want
to do the first analysis tasks on it we
can use the guest that's function that
I've just defined alright and this just
tells you that oK you've got you know
19,000 whatever tweets we read in 30000
but of course some of those were
retweets and they've been filtered out
then you've got the total character
count the time period right as I said
sometime in 2016 and the average tweet
tweet length and the average number of
retweets per tweet okay so that's the
first analysis task and then the second
one is the actually getting the top
lemmas which I'll show you with with
with this right so we get the top 20
lemmas just create a variable for that
and then I'm gonna visualize it
afterwards yeah this task does take
quite a long time because it needs to
build up this dictionary over all of the
tweets continuously so we might need to
wait for a little bit for that to
complete okay so that's done and I will
show you what that looks like as a
histogram this autocomplete would
actually decide to start working okay
all right yeah so here you can see the
histogram of the most common lemmas and
it's really nothing surprising right
you've got the name of the company and
then you've got a bunch of the very
small words that occur in natural
language very often and of course think
of course things like stock because
people use these symbols to talk about
the stock market you know and how the
companies are doing yeah so I mean this
is quite predictable and then finally we
can run the third analysis task which is
going to be well actually before we do
that I will need to load this sentiment
model
okay so now it's just going to take the
classifier and apply it and yeah so you
see the average it says that on average
76% of the tweets are positive I should
also mention that this takes a random
sample of only 1,000 tweets just so we
don't spend too much time on applying
the neural net so this may change from
time to time so I wouldn't be surprised
if I run this again it might be a little
different because there's an element of
random sampling okay but it's not so
maybe there's a maybe there's a random
seed somewhere so it's gonna be the same
okay or not so yeah as I said there's an
element of a random sampling because you
only take 1,000 samples from the tweets
and then apply the classifier to only
those 1,000 okay so that gives I think
that gives a pretty good overview of
what the analysis tasks are and now we
can actually get into running this
sequentially and then in parallel so we
can see what the performance benefit is
from doing it in parallel okay so I'm
just gonna make this array of the
tickers then we can run this loop with
all the tasks which will actually take
quite a bit of time it usually takes
like a minute or so so I'm going to have
some logging here as well
all right so as you can see task 2 takes
a long time because it's to do with
building up the the large dictionary of
most common lemmas and yeah you can run
this for yourselves if you like on your
machines as well
yeah and so after I've after I walked
through running it we can look at some
performance analysis with age stop okay
so this is completed and according to
this it took us about 65 seconds and it
should have returned this a dictionary
of the results of all the analysis tasks
that we've been looking at so if you
want to sort of analyze the output right
I mean this is basically what we've done
before for Amazon so you've got the
statistics of the tweets you've got the
histogram about the average sentiment
for 1,000 tweets or average estimated
sentiment I should say then you have the
same for Microsoft right so it's quite
similar data again you see that the name
of the company is the most common ulema
then you have the same similar sort of
thing for Netflix and then and then for
Google right and yet again this isn't
actually like extremely super useful but
it's just an Imagine sort of task where
you know for example you could be
working on let's say stock prediction
and you'd want to analyze the sentiment
of the market so you would you would be
doing some sentiment analysis on some
companies of course would be a bit more
sophisticated than that but it's just to
show you how how this would be done
sequentially right so I'm just gonna
clear the clear the output here okay and
so now we can look at how what it would
be like to run this in parallel so now
these require decorators actually become
important because this tells I by
parallel what the dependencies are so it
doesn't recognize necessarily these
imports at the top it doesn't care what
we import so it needs to be told
specifically what the dependencies are
and there are several ways of doing that
one of which is specifying it using
these decorators so you can see that
these functions depend on some modules
from the standard library and some
actual functions that have been defined
before like this right and you can see
see it here as well
and so in this function I'm just going
to run basically what was done in the in
a single iteration of this for loop so
I'm just going to I'm just going to run
that
so I'll just define this function and
now we need to actually launch a cluster
right because to use I PI parallel we
can't just launch it from the notebook
we need to go to a terminal and launch
an IP cluster so that's something I can
do here and I'm gonna use four engines
because we've got four pieces of data so
then that way we're going to get it's
the most logical sort of choice for the
amount of speed-up that we want to get
and eventually just say engines appeared
to have started successfully yeah sure
that's a good idea
alright yeah so the command that you
need to run is IP cluster star at minus
n and then the number of engines which
should be four given that we have four
companies to work on and yet when it
when it starts up successful you'll get
this message that says engines appear to
have started successfully okay so now
now that we've launched this IP cluster
we can we can actually create a client
object to connect to it and then create
something which is called a direct view
and the direct view is one of the
possible interfaces that I apply
parallel gives for for interacting with
the running cluster of engines the other
one is called a load balanced view which
and there are some pros and cons to
which one you can use the load balanced
view as the name suggests does a load
balancing so that makes it a bit more
efficient but there are some limitations
on how you can push dependencies and I
think it's I mean I'm not sure but I
don't think it's possible to use it on
remote machines but as I said I'm not
completely sure about that so but we're
going to use a direct view here which is
obtained using this slice operator and
we're going to execute the string here
which is going to import these relevant
packages on all four of these engines
I'm just gonna run that okay yes there's
just some warning but we just show you
what this looks like right so you see
this as a this directory object has the
direct awareness of these four engines
that are running the next step is we're
going to take these global variables
that we've all been sets that have been
used in the notebook and we're just
going to push them again to all of those
four engines so you run that and then we
can execute the actual parallel run of
this which is running this function in
parallel using using map so we run that
and as you can see there's obviously
like no printing going on because it
wouldn't work anyway so we'll just need
to wait for a while
now you can also run this in the mean
time yourselves if you like
yeah and so you can see it completed in
about half of the time and we can get
these results and compare them right so
again you can see it's the exact same
exact same thing so the same number of
tweets in character count same histogram
this obviously is different but it's
only different because of random
sampling so it's got nothing to do with
parallelism yeah and you can see that
okay these are the exact same results
and yeah you can see it only took half
of the time but it didn't necessarily
take a quarter of the time which is what
we would have expected and yeah so there
are several reasons for that and I'm
gonna just run this again with the H
double and we can see do a bit of
performance analysis on why it's taking
half of the time as compared to the
sequential implementation so I'll just
drag this over see if that's big enough
okay so we can run htough to show the
actual performance which again you can
do yourselves don't just shrink this
yeah I'll see if I can also sort the
processes by the number of CPUs that
it's using or by the percentage of CPU
load that it's using okay so now I'll
run this again and we can analyze why
it's taking the amount of time that it
is so this is running running now so you
can see there's not much activity now
it's doing the second task which is the
which is the building up of the
Dictionary of dilemmas and now it's
going to be doing the third task which
is the classification so I'll just wait
for this to run through and then I'll
comment on what we're seeing with this
performance behavior
okay so as you can see it's a it is the
code is sequential but you saw that
there are points in it where it's
actually using all of the CPUs to 100%
right which doesn't seem to make sense
given that it's written in a single
Python process right but the reason for
why that's happening is because one of
these tasks that were running on R is
actually using multiple processors
internally even though it is within one
Python process and the reason for that
is because we can see that we are using
this care as sentiment model and because
Kerris isn't written purely in Python
it's also go to C and C++ back-end you
can tell that it actually does use
multiple processors even though you call
it from a Python process but it itself
does use multiple processors so that is
why even though this was a sequential
implementation you saw that there were
there was this 100% usage across all of
the CPUs but clearly that that is that
is still slower than using I pi parallel
because it doesn't doesn't benefit from
parallelism in the other stages like
especially the second task which is
building up the dictionary so now I'm
just gonna run the second task again and
then you'll be able to see what the CPU
usage is like for that okay so you see
that the four CPUs that are being used
as the engines are being maxed out which
is not completely the same as what we
saw before and now but when we get to
the third analysis task you see that the
other four are going to be used as well
because of Karass is own implementation
okay and it's completed again about half
of the time so the takeaway point from
from this is just that yeah you can
benefit a lot by parallelizing
paralyzing different pieces of code or
so different yeah just your code on
different pieces of data but you just
also do need to be aware of what
underlying implementation there is in
your libraries because as we've seen
with Karis it already does have
parallelism embedded into itself so that
is something to be aware of but as I
said you know like this may not seem as
that big of a difference but if you
imagine you have a large computer with
you know 16 cores or something and a big
amount of memory then if you parallel I
something that you need to run on let's
say 10 pieces of data and you paralyze
it oh and you have the course that will
really save you a lot of time and
especially if it's something that takes
like an hour hour to do each like a
Monte Carlo simulation or something like
that so you'll be able to do it and
almost a tenth of the time if you don't
have if you don't have process the
processes inside it that actually are
using parallelism already so now yeah so
I think I've gone through this quite
quickly there is there's there's still
the case of debugging so that is
something that I can just quickly get
into so for debugging of the I pi
parallel just quit this
okay so one way to debug this process
would be let's say we can raise we could
raise an exception inside one of the
functions all right so first of all just
want to confirm that you can see that if
I just print something it's not gonna do
anything we're doing okay all right so I
try and print something like something I
run that all right I'll get it'll again
take like 20 to 30 seconds right so this
traditional way of debugging sequential
processes won't necessarily work and
also there is the issue of trying to
figure out which process the debugging
statement came from so I'll just wait
for this to well actually I'll just
terminate it at this point okay so as I
said before one way to debug these
processes is to use exceptions so if we
could for example go into this
pre-processing function we could say
that we can raise an exception with some
debugging statement right so you know in
reality you'd have like an if statement
that would check for something but here
we can just raise an error again we can
call it
just get rid of well we can keep that
anyway right and you see it immediately
raises the value error that we've
specified it says some debug statement
and as you can see it also raises it
four times and the reason it's raised
four times is because we've got four
independent engines and so yeah it
raises it for each one of those if we
wanted to only have an exception for one
of the engines then we could we could
just check for that so we could say for
example if the company is Amazon then we
could raise this error right and you can
see that so I'll just need to define it
here as well yeah so this time it's
gonna run a bit longer but then it will
actually raise the air and the reason it
runs a bit longer is because the three
other engines are still executing while
the air is going to be raised on one of
them that's running Amazon's
tweet processing
let's just double-check that
[Music]
yeah so you see that now only one error
has been raised because we only raised
them in one of the engines so exceptions
is one possible way to debug these
processes but another possibility is to
use logging so you can log from each
independent engine to a file and you can
read the file later on to see what sort
of happened and again this is actually
quite useful so let's say you've got
some tasks that takes an hour to do and
it's got multiple steps and multiple
simulations modeling within it things
like that and you think it might break
so in that case it's actually quite
useful to have logging statements but
then before and after each important
step so that you can then look at the
file and if it breaks you can see how
far the the engine or the process got
before it broke so I'm gonna just try
and run that okay so let me just get rid
of this exception first
it was just clear that out right so
before I actually show you this let me
just define this create logger function
so this uses the quite standard Python
logging module which is in the standard
library so you may already be familiar
with it and the way it's created as you
just you create use this get logger
function then I specify file handler
which is going to print out log files
into this folder then you can set a
logging level which is something that
logging uses internally so anything
below that level will not be will not be
logged even if you call the logging
function well that's not too relevant at
this point and then you excuse me then
you just specify the logging format
sorry yeah and then so yeah this is what
the function does it just creates this
logger that we're gonna use from the
parallel processes so we can go back and
as you can see it's also another
dependency in this IPP require right
which is another important thing for
managing dependencies in ëifí parallel
right so you just need to remember every
time that you use a dependency you need
to either import it from within the
function or you can use this decorator
to specify it so we're going to just
uncomment this and we can run it okay so
this is just gonna run again as normal
but then the idea is that it should
actually create some log files in this
folder that we can look at afterwards
I can just launch HD epic in so we see
the progress
okay yeah so here you can see these log
files that have just been created and
you can see in here there's this logging
message that we've just that we've just
written down right which just simply
says says this it says that this step
completed and like I said before if you
had some complicated workflow you could
take to take these logging messages and
do them in more detail so for example
what I can do is I can just I can also
show you how to do it from within one of
those one of those functions so let me
just delete these files
all right so we could log to those files
from this function but then we could
also have something more specific so
let's say we could go here and we could
try and import that logger function
and we would call it yeah which actually
doesn't make sense here because they
don't have access to the name of the
process so that is something that would
make sense to pass as an argument so I
can do that out here though all right so
I can change this function I can put in
the ticker I'll just say it has a non by
default and then I'll say that the name
of this logger is gonna be sentiment and
then we'll just add in the actual take
her name it'll create the logger and
then we can log from here saying
okay and then yeah then we can also have
another logging statement that's gonna
say okay so we'll run that and yeah just
see if it actually works
let me just read
let me just reset these things all right
so the idea is that it's supposed these
log files are just there for this
initial statement but then there should
be a second set of log files for actual
specific logging from within this
dysfunction I should start with
sentiment but I suppose it'll take a
while for it to get there because it
needs to get through the second task of
making those histograms okay because any
is specified as a keyword argument
just quickly delete those
yeah so I'll just wait for this to
finish yeah so now it's created those
more specific log files and we can read
from it once once it completes
okay so we can look at those
right so I mean should have been named a
bit better but yeah you get the idea
right so you can you at you can use
these independent imports within I by
parallel and then you can log to files
as a way of debugging the processes so
you know if it was a really long running
complicated task you could put in these
logging statements in multiple places
and make sure that yeah that you get the
logging messages and in case something
break you brakes you would be able to
see how far it got in the process from
the from the logging messages okay yeah
and then I guess for a final thing I
mean just to quickly quickly discuss you
it is possible to run by parallel on
remote machines and this actually is
also why it's good to use this direct
view at least for this presentation
because that is something you can you
can use to do that so there is something
I won't actually demonstrate it
necessarily but just to show you that
there is this DVD remote decorator yeah
I'm not gonna actually create a function
with it but it exists and you can you
can use it to decorate a function and
then that function would run on a remote
machine you could also you also should
be aware that if you want to run a
remote machines there's a sync imports
function so you could run with DV dot
sync imports and then you could import
these sorts of statements and that's
relevant when you're running on remote
machines because this will actually run
these imports it will run them
everywhere sorry I just need to get the
indentation right yeah right so this
sync imports is important when you're
running on multiple machines because it
imports it on all of them and then yeah
finally
yeah you can also use these push these
assignments to share global variables
between the engines and that will work
on remote machines as well
okay and yeah I think I think that's
pretty much it which I know is quite
early to to finish but I mean it's just
gone through it quite quickly let me
think if there's anything else I could I
could share so another interesting thing
is that you could run this map but
instead of map sync which means that you
will just it'll block until it executes
so it runs it in parallel but once once
you run it you have to wait for that
command to finish you could also use a
map async which would which you could
launch like this but and it wouldn't
block you could do other things while
this would run in the background but
then it would return presumably a future
object that you would then get and then
that would force it to to return the
value okay so so yeah I mean I think
that's that that is all I wanted to show
I'm sorry that it's going to be quite
this early but yeah I did go through all
of the points so yeah but I mean I guess
that means we can have a really long Q&A
so so if you have any questions feel
free to feel free to ask me yeah
yeah please
[Music]
yeah I mean I think you would just
capture yeah I mean well you could do a
try-catch right and then in the try or
try accept and then in the exception
block you could just capture the message
output of the error as an object and
then you could lock that into a file so
that is that's how I would do it yeah
yep it is more complicated but it is
possible I mean I there are shared
memory data structures that I know you
can use in multi and pythons multi
processing module yeah I've used as well
I'm not sure in high parallel if you
could use that I think you probably
could but I mean I haven't I haven't I
haven't used it I mean the memory like
you said is a limitation and that is
something you could get around by having
multiple remote machines to run on but
yeah I understand your point about the
shared memory which I I'm not really not
sure if that's available but I mean I
would be surprised if it wasn't there
well I
to be honest I find it quite similar
actually like the workflow I think is
not that different yeah it's just a bit
more convenient to run from a notebook
because yeah you could just launch the
cluster on the side and then you can
connect to it and also I think with the
load balanced view I think also it you
have the benefit of it just actually
figuring out you know if one thing is
taking much longer we can put a bit of
work on another processor and things
like that
yeah in the back there yeah you
mentioned this thing about having nested
parallel processes like you said Karis
hazard yeah this is written in C++ it's
already paralyzed what what do you do in
these circumstances I feel a bit
confused when this happens and I just
run it for the most out of processor if
I'm doing my model is a random forest in
scikit-learn
and I you can put any jobseeker minus
one but then you want to put it through
a grid search like a random search and
then you go paralyzation there as well
cross-validation what's your advice in
the circumstances at which which one
should you trigger the parallelism on
for okay well I would I think once just
say I mean it depends on your it depends
on your situation I think in general
like in general the native parallelism
of the libraries is probably going to be
faster just because it's implemented in
something much more low-level and it's
that way it's probably going to be
faster but with that being said if you
have something deeply embedded into a
workflow that's already parallelized
then it might make sense to just run
that native thing with one CPU just so
you don't have to take it then take it
out and then just use the native
parallelism on that so I would say it
really depends on your on your workflow
yeah so you mentioned that you can run
tasks yeah is there any requirement for
the machines to so there is this JSON
config file I believe that you set up on
the on the machines and I mean yeah I
think it really depends on what kind of
frameworks you're using so you can use
MPI for example but I think one way to
do it is you can just have this IP
cluster still running on your localhost
but you can have these remote machines
being configured to listen in in for
connections for my parallel and being
used that way
any other question yeah okay one last
one let's go that I have a question do
you have any comparison with other like
loosing the space like for example dusk
I think it's doing
yeah I've seen their space yes I've
heard of that but I haven't have
actually used it so I wouldn't be able
to tell you all right so I think if
that's everything yeah okay great yes
thank you very much
[Applause]